[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich Ihnen und gemeinsam mit mir
im Studio ist Sven Voss für den Sport
achso mir einen schönen guten Abend und
die Blicke sind auf Berlin gerichtet
worauf werden sich SPD Grüne und FDP
einigen
Koalitionsausschuss zweiter Teil es gibt
leidenschaftliche Debatten heißt es aber
immer noch kein Ergebnis
wie viele lng-terminals braucht
Deutschland kritiker sagen die Regierung
habe am Bedarf vorbei geplant
und an ihn werden sie sich gewöhnen
müssen Thomas Tuchel stimmt sein Team
auf den Klassiker gegen den BVB ein
ja wir alle hatten gedacht dass wir
jetzt bereits Ergebnisse des
Koalitionsausschusses haben werden aber
der Tag noch Ende offen denn zwischen
SPD grün und FDP gibt es einige große
streith Themen welche zeigt den Volker
Lucek
ein großer Knackpunkt vor allem zwischen
FDP und Grünen ein schneller Ausbau von
Autobahn und Straßen ohne uns sagen die
Grünen für sie gilt der Ausbau der
Schienennetzes als Priorität
Stichwort Verbot von Gas und
erdölheizung Zuschüsse für neue Heizung
die sogenannte Abwrackprämie für alte
Heizung die FDP ist gegen ein pauschales
Verbot zwar haben sich die ampelparteien
dafür ausgesprochen möglichst ab 2024
nur noch neue Heizungen mit mindestens
65% erneuerbarer Energie zuzulassen
Teile der FDP haben dagegen aber immer
wieder Bedenken geäußert
für die Kinder Grundsicherung ab 2025
machen sich die Grünen stark als Antwort
auf steigende Kinderarmut Widerspruch
bei der FDP sie hält die aktuellen
kindergelderhöhungen für ausreichend das
sind sie also die Knackpunkte der
Bundeskanzler sieht jedoch große
Fortschritte bei dem Beratungen er traf
sich heute zwischendurch mit dem
kenianischen Präsidenten aber auch da
wurde nach dem Koalitionsausschuss
gefragt wer von petermann
kenius Staatspräsident Ruto in
Deutschland sein Land sollte im
Mittelpunkt stehen an diesem Nachmittag
im Bundeskanzleramt doch schnell dreht
sich das Interesse in Richtung Marathon
Koalitionsausschuss
ich bin sehr sehr froh über diese
Gespräche wir kommen konstant voran wir
haben die hauptsächlichen Fragen die zu
lösen waren längst gelöst es geht jetzt
noch viele Details die natürlich auch zu
einem guten Gesamtwerk passen sollen
nichts Konkretes wieder nicht Scholz
geht zurück zum Streit in der
Ampelkoalition seit Sonntagabend mit
Unterbrechung beraten die Spitzen
Einigung ja vielleicht dann doch wieder
nicht Klimaschutz Schienen versus
Autobahnausbau Verbot von Öl und
Gasheizungen grüne gegen FDP und die SPD
irgendwo dazwischen es kracht und es
dauert selbst für einen grünen
länderchef schon heute Mittag viel zu
lang scharfe Kritik
ich finde 19 Stunden Sitzung zu machen
für die schönen
Zeichen von Führungsschwäche des
Kanzlers für die Union ist das eine
Steilvorlage das Klima in der
Ampelkoalition sei vergiftet
man muss es mittlerweile so sagen wir
haben ganz offensichtlich in Deutschland
eine Regierungskrise die Bundesregierung
eignet sich eignet sich in den
wesentlichen Fragen der deutschen
Politik nicht mehr
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat immer wieder
betont das Land brauche mehr
Geschwindigkeit die Ampel in der
Sackgasse oder doch bald der Durchbruch
Gespräche oder Streit was auch immer es
dauert an im Bundeskanzleramt
der Koalitionsausschuss Takt also immer
noch Theo Colin Berlin was ist denn da
los
ja das war heute nachmittag kurios der
Kanzler hat in der Pressekonferenz quasi
ein politisches Weihnachten und Ostern
zusammen angekündigt es werde sehr sehr
gute Ergebnisse geben es gehe um die
größte Modernisierung einer
Volkswirtschaft und die hauptsächlichen
Fragen habe man längst geklärt es gehe
nur noch um die Details die aber scheint
es dann doch in sich zu haben denn nach
einem mittlerweile rund 30 stündigen
Verhandlungsmarathon sind die
Koalitionäre noch immer nicht fertig am
späten Nachmittag schien es schon
geschafft und dann machte eine Partei
den Sack wieder auf wenn man sehr wohl
meint ist dann könnte man es im
Schildchen Sinne der Größe der Aufgabe
zuschreiben dann aber liegt die
Messlatte jetzt für das Ergebnis sehr
hoch und könnte es aber auch als Beleg
nehmen für eine schwach geführte und den
Kernthemen Kilometer auseinander
liegende Koalition die Bewertung dürfte
sich auch am Verhandlungsergebnis
entscheiden wann immer das dann kommen
sollte danke schön
schauen wir nach Brüssel jetzt ist es
beschlossene Sache in der EU gilt ab
2035 ein weitgehendes Verbot für neue
Autos mit Verbrennermotor dafür gaben
heute die Ministerin und Minister der
EU-Staaten grünes Licht die für den
Bereich energiezuständig sind das ganze
ist Teil des green Deal des
klimaschutzplans der EU über die
Maßnahmen gibt es aber
Auseinandersetzungen ultra berichtet
Europa als grüner Kontinent im
Werbevideo der EU existiert das
ehrgeizige Ziel schon
klimaneutral bis 2050 zu sein deshalb ab
2035 dürfen keine Neuwagen verkauft
werden die mit Benzin oder Diesel fahren
es ist damit der Weg frei zu 100% der
missionsfreier Mobilität bis 2035 die
Bundesregierung setzte durch das auch
danach Verbrenner Autos zugelassen
werden dürfen die mit klimaneutralen
Kraftstoffen sogenannten e-fuels bekannt
werden
strittig heute im energierat der Umgang
mit Atomenergie weil sie emissionsfrei
ist wollen die Befürworter der
Atomenergie sie als grüne Energie
deklarieren dann würde es dafür auch
EU-Fördergelder geben
erneuerbare Energien und Atomenergie
gleichzusetzen aber für die
Emissionsreduzierung und den Wettbewerb
auf dem Strommarkt spielt eben die
Atomenergie noch eine wichtige
rollektiv wenn die Franzosen jetzt
weitermachen mit diesen Verlangen der
alten Atomkraftwerke und die werden alte
Atomkraftwerke werden immer wieder
ausfallen dann haben wir ein Risiko in
Europa der Streit um die Atomenergie
belastet Europas Umweltpolitik
alle in der EU wollen Klimaschutz aber
nicht um jeden Preis atomkraft ja bitte
Verbrenner aus nein danke nationale
Wirtschaftsinteressen bestimmen die
Politik
die EU sucht Auswege aus der Klimakrise
und muss aufpassen dass nationale
Egoismen Europas Zukunftsprojekt nicht
untergraben
über easius wird gerade viel diskutiert
wenn sie es noch mal genau wissen wollen
schauen Sie in die ZDF heute App dort
erklären wir wie werden sie hergestellt
was sind die Nachteile und wie effizient
sind sie im Vergleich zu E-Autos und
Verbrenner
unser Erdgas kommt aus Russland das galt
bis zum ukrainekrieg dann musste in
kürzester Zeit plötzlich Ersatz her
dabei setzte die Regierung massiv auf
flüssiggasterminals in den nächsten vier
Jahren sollen voraussichtlich neun
Terminals entstehen und zwar den
Standorten Wilhelmshaven Brunsbüttel
Stade und Lubmin wenn alle in Betrieb
sind kann Deutschland anderthalb Mal
mehr Gas importieren als Russland uns
vor dem Krieg lieferte zu viel des Guten
wird kritisiert Moll in ihlau berichtet
der Startschuss für den Bau einer
weiteren Pipeline Norddeutschland Olaf
Lies Niedersachsens Wirtschaftsminister
setzt den Spatenstich für den Bau einer
70 km langen Röhre hierdurch wird das
Gas vom LNG Terminal in Wilhelmshaven
Insel Landesinnere geleitet und dann ins
Netz eingespeist 4 Millionen Haushalte
könnten dann schätzungen zufolge mit
Erdgas versorgt werden später soll die
Leitung für Wasserstoff verwendet werden
wir werden mehr Gas importieren müssen
wir müssen mehr Infrastruktur bauen wir
wollen die Vorbereitung für
klimaneutrales Gas in die Pipeline bei
der wir heute beginnen ist wieder so ein
Baustein mit der wir
Versorgungssicherheit gewährleisten mit
großem Tempo und mit großen Mengen LNG
verflüssigtem Erdgas plant derzeit die
Regierung in kommenden Jahr sollen
bereits 37 Milliarden Kubikmeter Gas
über die Terminals importiert werden bis
2030 soll es sogar jährlich 76
Milliarden sein zur Erinnerung 55
Milliarden Kubikmeter russisches Gas
gilt es zu ersetzen
nötig sei diese Überkapazität betont die
Bundesregierung ein großzügiger
Sicherheitspuffer für Deutschlands
Energiesicherheit Wissenschaftler und
Umweltschützer fürchten um Klimaziele
wir stehen im Grunde vor der
Entscheidung setzen wir jetzt auf 100%
erneuerbare und nutzen Gas nur noch für
den Übergang oder schaffen wir jetzt
große gaskapazitäten und haben dann eben
noch Jahrzehnte fossiles Gas im System
mit letzterem können wir die Klimaziele
nicht erreichen eine weitere Sorge wenn
der Gasverbrauch langfristig sinkt dann
stünden Investitionsruinen an der
deutschen Küste die Gesamtkosten für die
lng-terminals belaufen sich derzeit auf
10 Milliarden Euro die spätere Umrüstung
auf Wasserstoff noch nicht eingerechnet
eine interessante Entscheidung für
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher nach
Abschluss einer privaten Insolvenz
werden die Daten von der Schufa nur noch
sechs Monate gespeichert bisher waren es
drei Jahre die Schufa reagiert damit auf
ein bevorstehendes Urteil des
Europäischen Gerichtshofes durch eine
Verbraucherinsolvenz können sich
Privatleute von ihren Schulden befreien
auch wenn sie nicht alles zurückzahlen
können
einen Tag nach dem bundesweiten
großstreik rollt der Verkehr wieder
weitgehend normal auch heute ist das
befürchtete Chaos ausgeblieben bei der
Bahn kam es lauter im Sprecher am Morgen
zwar vereinzelt zu Ausfällen die meisten
Züge fahren aber nach Plan kaum
Einschränkungen auch an den Flughäfen
wie hier in Köln-Bonn mussten insgesamt
nur wenige Flüge annulliert werden
auch in Frankreich wird gestreikt und
protestiert heute erneut aus Ärger um
die Rentenreform von Präsident macron
auch in diesem zehnten Aktionstag ging
landesweit 100.000 Menschen auf die
Straße die Anhebung des Rentenalters ist
bereits durch das Parlament derzeit
befasst sich der Verfassungsrat damit
über die Proteste berichtet Thomas Walde
in Rennen begann der Tag mit Feuer und
einer Blockade der Autobahn am Gardel
Lyon blockierten ausgerechnet
Eisenbahner die Bahngleise und in Paris
sperrten Schüler ihre Schule Stillstand
in Frankreich auch inhaltlich eine
Ernährung im Streit um die Rentenreform
zeichnet sich nicht ab die Frage des
deutschen Fernsehens nach einem
Kompromiss stößt auf Unverständnis
Kompromiss machen wir nicht es gibt nur
einen möglichen Kompromiss die Regierung
spricht mit uns und zieht ihre Reform
zurück vor allem die Erhöhung auf 64
Jahre die Regierung bekräftigte dagegen
heute im Parlament nicht am Kern ihrer
Reform rütteln zu lassen vor allem nicht
an der Erhöhung des
Renteneintrittsalters
mit dieser Reform verfolgen wir ein Ziel
die umlagefinanzierte Rente zu erhalten
die Solidarität zwischen den
Generationen und ein defizitäres System
dauerhaft abzusichern
heute gingen weniger Menschen auf die
Straße als zuletzt und auch die Streik
Beteiligung bröckelt weniger Lehrer
waren im Ausstand morgen wollen viele
Straßenreiniger in Paris die Arbeit
wieder aufnehmen geringere Beteiligung
kein Kompromiss in Sicht wie schon in
den vergangenen Tagen kam es heute auch
wieder zu Ausschreitungen in Rennen Nord
und zur Stunde in Paris etwa es gab
zahlreiche Festnahmen die Behörden
fürchten dass die radikaleren Kräfte
verstärkt den Ton angeben
erneut gab es in den USA eine Attacke in
einer Grundschule drei Kinder und drei
Erwachsene wurden Nashville Tennessee
getötet die Person die die Tat verübte
wurde von der Polizei erschossen
US-Präsident beiden ordnete an die
Flaggen im ganzen Land zu Ehren der
Opfer dieser Zitat sinnlosen Gewalttat
auf Halbmast zu setzen Claudia Bates
die Grundschüler werden in Sicherheit
gebracht Hand in Hand verlassen sie den
Ort des Grauens der bis kurz zuvor ihre
Idylle war eine kleine christliche
Privatschule draußen in einem
wohlhabenden Grünen vor Ort von
Nashville um zehn nach zehn begann der
Albtraum die Polizei spricht von einer
Schützin die sich den Weg frei schoss
und dann wahllos um sich feuerte die
28-Jährige Audrey sei selbst früher
Schülerin dieser Schule gewesen
identifiziere sich mittlerweile als Mann
das Motiv sei unklar bisher habe man nur
Vermutungen
wir glauben dass es möglicherweise
Verbitterung darüber gab an diese Schule
gehen zu müssen wir haben noch nicht
alle Details aber das vielleicht deshalb
diese Tat geschah
Audrey Harf verübte die Tat mit zwei
Sturmgewehren und einer Handfeuerwaffe
legal erworben Präsident beiden forderte
wieder strengere Waffengesetze
wir müssen mehr gegen Waffengewalt tun
sie zerreißt unsere Gemeinden zerreißt
die Seele unserer Nation
doch auch nach dem brutalen Tod der
kleinen Kinder ist das mit den
Republikanern nicht zu machen
lass uns jetzt nicht über Politik reden
und über Gefühle Emotionen fühlen sich
gut an lösen aber keine Probleme warum
reden wir nicht über das wahre Problem
im Zusammenhang mit dieser Schießerei
und das wäre mentale Gesundheit
Sturmgewehre sind für die Republikaner
nicht das Problem Tatsache ist
Schusswaffen sind die Todesursache
Nummer eins für Kinder in den USA
schauen wir nach Mexiko in der Nähe der
Grenze zu den USA hatte es in einer
Unterkunft für Migrantinnen und
Migranten gebrannt dabei kamen
mindestens 39 Menschen ums Leben 29
weitere wurden verletzt laut dem
mexikanischen Präsidenten zündeten die
Menschen ihre Matratzen an nachdem sie
von ihrer drohenden Abschiebung erfahren
hatten das Feuer sei daraufhin außer
Kontrolle geraten
für amnest international ist 2022 ein
Jahr der Flucht unter Massenproteste dem
Westen wirft die
Menschenrechtsorganisation Doppelmoral
vor die entschlossene Reaktion auf
russlandsaggression gegen die Ukraine
stehen in scharfen Kontrast zur
Rücksicht bei Verbündeten wie Israel
Saudi-Arabien und Ägypten
scharf kritisiert Ernest sie auch das
brutale Vorgehen Irans gegenüber der
dortigen Protestbewegung Stefanie Hein
Mariam Claren hat am Morgen mit ihrer
Mutter telefoniert das ist nicht
selbstverständlich denn die deutsche
rheinische Frauenrechtlerin nahit
targary sitzt wegen ihres Engagements im
Gefängnis in Iran seit Oktober 2020 sie
ist 68 Jahre alt sie hat Bluthochdruck
sie hat Diabetes sie hat mehrfache
Bandscheibenvorfälle sie ist eigentlich
haftunfähig Iran reagiert auf Kritik mit
Härte im letzten Jahr kam es zu massiven
Protesten Auslöser der Tod einer jungen
Frau die zuvor von der Sitten Polizei
verhaftet worden war der Slogan Frau
Leben Freiheit geht um die Welt Iran ist
einer der Schwerpunkte bei der
Vorstellung des aktuellen amnestyreports
Protest und Flucht sind die wesentlichen
Themen weltweit fliehen und protestieren
Menschen weil ihr Leben bedroht ist weil
sie unterdrückt verfolgt und entrechtet
werden kurz weil ihre Menschenrechte
verletzt sind auch wegen Russlands Krieg
gegen die Ukraine 8 Millionen Menschen
so der Report sind im letzten Jahr aus
der Ukraine geflüchtet auf diesen
Angriff haben eu- und Weltgemeinschaft
sehr schnell reagiert Amnesty nennt es
Doppelmoral das bei
Menschenrechtsverletzungen in Ländern
wie China Ägypten oder Saudi-Arabien die
weltweit weniger konsequent sei starten
wir die Bundesrepublik dürfen nicht
länger mit zweierlei Maß messen in ihren
Außenbeziehungen mit Staaten sondern
müssen überall auf die Einhaltung der
internationalen Ordnung und die Achtung
der Menschenrechte dringen die
Menschenrechtserklärung war die Antwort
auf die Barbarei des Zweiten Weltkriegs
bei der Umsetzung bleibt bis heute viel
zu tun
zum Sport Sven da hat er das IOC heute
für Aufsehen gesorgt ja denn das
Internationale Olympische Komitee will
das russische und belarussische
Athletinnen und Athleten bald wieder in
den Weltsport zurückkehren mit seiner
Empfehlung erntet IOC-Präsident thomas
Bach viel Kritik auch aus Deutschland
die fechtwelt bietet im EOC die Stirn in
einem offenen Brief ist gegen eine
Rückkehr von Russen und Belarussen in
den Weltsport Russlands Aggression
verstößt nicht nur gegen die Normen des
Völkerrechts sondern auch gegen die
grundlegenden Werte des olympicismus
darunter Frieden Völker Verständigung
die Achtung der Menschenwürde und der
Menschenrechte das IOC dagegen empfiehlt
bei seiner Tagung der Exekutive in
Lausanne Nord es ist keine Grauzone des
internationalen Rechts es ist von
derartiger Wichtigkeit dass wir es als
sie zwingende Norm des Völkerrechts
bezeichnen aus diesem Grund kann das
pauschale Verbot russischer und Bella
russischer Sportler nicht
aufrechterhalten werden
continue die folgenschilder die deutsche
Florett Europameisterin Leonie Ebert
gerade von einem Weltcup zurück unsere
ukrainischen Fechterinnen haben schon
beschlossen dass sie an keinem Wettkampf
teilnehmen werden an dem russischer
Athleten teilnehmen und auch die
deutsche Politik äußert sich ich bin
sehr enttäuscht weil ich finde die
Entscheidung des IOCs ist ein Schlag ins
Gesicht aller ukrainischen Sportlerinnen
Sportler ein Jahr vor Paris steht der
olympische Sport vorbeugen und eine
Zerreißprobe
die deutsche Fußballnationalmannschaft
spielt heute Abend gegen Belgien deshalb
hatte der neue Bayern-Trainer Thomas
Tuchel nur einige Spieler zur Verfügung
bei seinem ersten Training in München
bekanntes Gesicht neue Kleider alte
Leidenschaft Thomas der neue
bayerntrainer heute beim ersten Training
ohne die Nationalspieler Kaltstart vom
Kracher gegen Dortmund es ist ja
trotzdem so dass wir dann den den den
den den Druck lieben den Stress
liebender das ist das was mein Leben
ausmacht und meine Leidenschaft für das
Spiel und Titel die soll Tuchel Bayern
bescheren vom Pott über die Schale bis
zum DFB-Pokal den er zuletzt zwei 17 mit
Dortmund gewann gegen eben diese
Dortmunder am Samstag das Ziel klar es
geht ums Gewinnen es geht auch um die
Art und Weise des Gewinns aber es geht
ums Gewinnen Tuchel muss nun schnell
funktionieren ob und wie seine Art
verfängt zeigen die nächsten Wochen
sehr spannend mit dem neuen in München
Dankeschön Sven derzeit Pendel das
Wetter ständig hin und her heute
schneeschau am Osten morgen
frühlingsmilde 18 Grad im Südwesten mehr
dazu gleich von Katja horneffer Marietta
Slomka hat um 21 Uhr das heute journal
für Sie auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend da hat es doch tatsächlich
noch mal für eine Neuschneeauflage
gereicht besonders hier im Nordosten da
waren noch mal so ein bis vier
Zentimeter Schnee drin dann aber
lockerte es mir und mehr auf die Sonne
kam zum Vorschein und jetzt werden die
Wolken von Westen wieder dichter und
bringen auch regen zum Teil auch
Schneeregen mit heute Nacht hier im
Nordwesten und auch im Südwesten im
Osten ist dagegen trocken zum Teil auch
klar dort wird es dann am kältesten da
sinken die Temperaturen bis -4 Grad im
Westen ist es schon deutlich milder weil
wir hatten von 6 bis 1 Grad da geht der
Schneeregen im Laufe der Nacht auch mehr
und mehr in Regen über und morgen liegen
die Höchsttemperaturen in Vorpommern in
der Lausitzen auch in Nordfriesland bei
acht oder neun Grad sonst werden
zweistellige Werte erreicht und am
Neckar am Rhein und an der Mosel wird
frühlingshaft mit 15 bis 18 Grad die
Sonne werden sie morgen in der
Nordosthälfte nicht zu Gesicht bekommen
und am Vormittag kann es an der Küste
auch noch leicht regnen Freund hier
sieht es im Südwesten aus da zeigt sich
mal die Sonne allerdings sie noch einige
kleinere Regenschauer durch der
Donnerstag wird ein sehr durchwachsen
und wechselhaft der Freitag in Südwesten
stürmisch und der Samstag an der Ostsee
merklich kälter guten Abend